bad enoch 59 votes
mordent 92 votes
sunak 118 votes
trust 86 votes
there was one spoiled ballot paper
we had uh a full term we had one vote
not cast
um so kemi badanok
is eliminated from the election the
remaining three candidates will proceed
to a final ballot at the parliamentary
party tomorrow this will take place
i mean this time i will take place
between one and three
with a result declared at four o'clock
tomorrow
um let's just recap the figures for you
then uh kemi badanok is out of the tory
leadership race she got 59 votes and
that's the same and that means she is
out of the running
and then there were three uh rishi sunak
getting the most votes 118. that's three
more than he got in the last round by my
calculation penny mordent um the second
highest number of votes with 92 10 more
than she got in the last round of voting
and liz trust is on
86. um and i'm just trying to do the
maths on that that is nine
about 12 more i think actually beth will
know more let's bring back in our
political editor beth rigby and so kemi
badanok gone um and as you said before
that's probably no surprise but the big
question is who does she put her support
behind now out of those final three yeah
i i think i think i stray that the fast
thing to say about it is that bad enough
did not make progress in fact she went
worn back so what do we know from that
the right is now coalescing around liz
trust she has had a good run there she
has added 15 votes from the last round
that is good momentum for liz trust the
right now coalescing some of badernock's
vote may be going to her let's see with
that but then also with penny mordant
she's gone from 81 to 92 so 11 of the
tom
tugan heart vote so i'm just looking
around to see what mps are here uh 11 of
the uh
tougan heart votes have gone to morden
so now look at that it's a real battle
between mordent and trust
rishi sunak didn't quite get past the
120 threshold but let's see where the
bada knot votes break now will she go to
liz trust
will she break for rishi sunat will
michael gove break for rishi sanak he
backed badanok where will he go there
are
59 votes up for grabs and it will be
those votes that decide whether it's liz
trust or penny morden in to the final
two there is now just uh six votes uh
um uh dividing uh the two women this is
such a tight run race to get to the
final two so let's see how the bad knot
breaks now but rishi sunak not quite
over the line actually there